I'm Dom Degnan Dean of Faculty at the
Gaylord school and one of my favorite
quotes comes from the book Walden by
Henry David Thoreau unit Thoreau
describes his time at Walden Pond where
he was there for reflection and he
writes and Here I am sort of
interpreting a little bit that he went
to the woods to have a chance to think
and reflect on the state of life and the
world and in the book he writes the
admonition which is my favorite quote to
beware of enterprises that require new
clothes and if you travel to Walden Pond
now you quickly discover that directly
across the street from Walden Pond is a
Walden breezes trailer park complete
with all the amenities and if you go
further down the road from Walden Pond
you will find the substantial Concord
landfill and dump and the odors and the
seagulls from the Concord landfill and
dump when the wind is right float over
Thoreau's Walden Pond so the question is
where do we go today to have the luxury
of contemplation and learning and most
of us who are here at Gaylord school
appreciate the joy being in an
environment where one can explore ideas
and develop the skills necessary to
function in today's world and that's why
we have a sequential seventh through
twelfth grade interdisciplinary
curriculum that's why we require all
students to participate in community
service that's why one of Geller's goals
is to help our students become
insightful world citizens one of the
ways in which we enhance our program is
to come together as we have today as a
group and to consider issues and ideas
that affect us all and today is one of
those occasions we are going to continue
our discussion of affluenza to get us
started I have the good fortune to
introduce Thomas Naylor who will be
speaking to us this afternoon professor
nailers presentation will be followed by
shorter presentations by faculty members
Rob Williams Victoria Chase and students
Emily bug and Sam Libby and then all of
us will have some time to ask some
questions and comment on today's topic I
personally wish the row were here but
since he's not let me tell you a little
bit about Thomas Naylor thomas nailer
professor emeritus of economics at Duke
University
versity he's a writer social critic who
is taught at Middlebury College he's
co-author of one of the first text books
on computer stimulation techniques he's
taught economics management science and
computer science at Duke University for
30 years in international management
consultant specializing in strategic
management dr. Naylor has consulted with
governments and major corporations in
over 30 countries during the 1970s he
was president of simply on systems a
50:50 person computer software firm
whose clients were Fortune 500 companies
here and abroad professor nailer was one
of the first to predict in the New York
Times the massive changes in the former
Soviet Union and the Eastern Empire
where he traveled frequently in the
1980s in 1993 he his wife Magdalena and
their son Alexander who most of us know
is now a student here in our ninth grade
moved to Vermont in search of community
he writes about simple living the search
for meaning and community and Vermont a
kinder gentler metaphor for America
the New York Times International Herald
Tribune Los Angeles Times Boston Globe
Christian Science Monitor the nation and
Business Week have all published his
articles downsizing the USA and
affluenza are the most recent of his 29
books he is currently completing a book
entitled Vermont manifesto so I'd like
you to welcome dr. Thomas Naylor
good afternoon I would like to welcome
you to this song for among effluence or
the all-american bug I'll get in with a
summary overview of what I'm going to
talk about this afternoon at the outset
I will give a kind of philosophical
treatise of the root causes underlying
effluent so from there look at some of
the driving forces that are promoting or
hyping this all-encompassing disease
then examine the environmental
implications of effluent saw as well as
more recently some of the implications
on global terrorism
then we'll conclude with an overview of
the medical metaphor that we're using
throughout the book effluence a-- and
finally Vermont as a case study in
affluenza are you spending more and
enjoying it less these days both you and
your family do you say to your parents
I'm bored I don't have anything to do
even though your room is full of
high-tech gadgets including a TV a VCR
stereo a computer with all the bells and
whistles a DVD player video games and a
stack of CDs at least this high and
didn't you just return my family trip to
Disney World and no longer content just
with a Honda isn't the family
contemplating either a BMW are a large
gas-guzzling SUV sometime in your future
and even though you've enjoyed skiing it
stole for years are you now considering
either Aspen or Whistler for the next
family outing in terms of skiing and for
sure next summer you're headed for
Europe on the next family vacation how
many times have your credit cards maxed
out lately
families credit cards what draws you to
the mall even though you hate crowds and
you complain about the schmaltzy piped
in music the insipid smells the fake
glitter and all of the plastic yuck you
enjoy working so hard you and your
family to pay for all the stuff the
family buys stuff which more often than
not just sits around being used by no
one without realizing it you may be
suffering from a highly contagious
malady affluenza millions have been
infected with this virus which
originated in the United States but is
spread throughout the world affluenza is
an obsession with materialism with
consumer goods and services ranging from
beer cosmetics clothes cigarettes soft
drinks junk food video games rock music
to automobiles computers expensive homes
high-tech health care and international
travel in addition to viral
overconsumption those infected with
affluence or often suffer from overwork
stress consumer fatigue syndrome
information overload and surely stock
market delirium it affects both the rich
and poor alike the more you have the
more you want as a nation we're so
obsessed with having that we've lost our
ability to be human beings our happiness
depends mostly on our superiority over
others our power and our ability to
manipulate others capitalist America may
be the most efficient the most
productive nation in the world but it
extracts a high human cost to cope with
the meaninglessness and enough fear of
nothingness many of us spend our entire
lives pretending that we were invincible
one of the ways in which we try to
convince ourselves that we can live
forever is through conspicuous
consumption consumption seduces us into
believing that we can find security and
certainty and an otherwise uncertain and
meaningless world we think we can spend
our way into a
of never-ending self-actualization
without paying any psychological dues
whatsoever for our life of unrestrained
pleasure we live by the slogan I've got
mine Jack our sense of meaning rests
almost entirely on what we own what we
possessed and consumed rather than on
who we are somehow enough never seems to
be quite enough but for capitalism to
work effectively those who do the work
must believe that the path to happiness
involves accumulating enough money and
credit so that we can purchase a nicely
furnished home a couple of automobiles a
computer a boat and a college education
for our kids to be able to afford all
these things we must work hard until we
retire the harder we work the more money
we'll have the more we can buy and the
happier we'll be at least so the story
goes but if that were really true why
are so many people in the United States
so anxious so angry so unhappy so
cynical and stressed out why are the
rates of divorce suicide depression
abortion substance abuse and
incarceration so high if the American
Dream is the working working the way
it's supposed to work although real per
capita personal consumption expenditure
is nearly tripled over the last
half-century reaching $22,000 per person
or a total of 6 trillion dollars for the
nation as a whole the percentage of
people claiming to be very happy in our
country actually declined by 5 percent
over the last 50 years and the index of
social health decreased by 50 percent
since 1973 even though we live in a
period of unprecedented prosperity it's
also the time of the Living Dead many of
fluent Americans who deny themselves
virtually nothing in the way of material
satisfaction seem to be more dead than
alive is no novelist Walker Percy once
said
there is indeed something worse than
being deprived of life it's being
deprived of life and not even knowing it
many of us who are infected with
effluence up behaviors though we were
spiritually emotionally and
intellectually dead the Living Dead can
be found everywhere surfing the internet
checking their email messages
frequenting internet chat rooms day
trading glued to CNN hoping for an event
and an otherwise uneventful life driving
across town to Walmart in search of more
low-priced plastic yuck
stopping at McDonald's for a quick tasty
meal or perhaps feigning interest in a
mindless bureaucratic job our government
and our politicians and the high priests
of corporate America plus strings our
entire economy is driven by our intense
psychological need to fill our spiritual
and emotional vacuum with more and more
stuff and the illusion that the
accumulation of wealth and material
possessions can actually provide meaning
to life if we feel down and need a lift
we buy a new dress have a nice dinner
and restaurant or rent a video the less
meaning we have in our life the easier
it is to be seduced by the materialistic
work hard play hard
be happy syndrome a syndrome that turns
out to be based on a lie although drug
addiction is illegal addiction to
consumer goods merchandise catalogs
shopping malls cyber shopping and credit
cards is encouraged by every form of
advertising in our country from
Washington and corporate America the
message is always the same buy now and
save for retirement later if we don't
play that play the game the whole house
of cards may come tumbling down we have
a patriotic duty to consume to be a good
American is to be a big consumer whoever
dies with the most toys wins the game
the global economy is the altar in which
consumers investors alike worship the
market is our God so important is
meaninglessness to our economy that
Chicago business economies
inhale once said the only way to save
the global economy is through profligate
Americans consumerism appearing before
Congress on one occasion a couple of
years ago that a Reserve Board Chairman
Alan Greenspan congratulated the
American people on the performance of
the US economy and what exactly had we
done to deserve such an accolade spend
money like it was going out of style
Greenspan's worst nightmare is that
through some medical spiritual or
psychological miracle and elixir a cure
might emerge which would significantly
reduce the incidence of affluenza and
render monetary policies impotent just
like in Japan they have near zero
interest rates when the interest rate is
zero it's very difficult to to drop it
any lower and impact consumption if
they're enough meaningless in America to
keep the global economy afloat maybe
maybe not meaninglessness breeds
affluenza and affluenza breeds more
meaninglessness since there are no easy
cures for either meaninglessness or
overconsumption is absolutely nothing
other than ourselves to prevent us from
spending ourselves into oblivion like
Eva Peron in the Broadway musical Evita
we're supposed to have been immortal but
in the end we can't deliver
early on my remarks I suggested that uh
that affluenza was a young originated in
the United States actually that's not
quite correct
affluenza has been around for centuries
but until recently it was more the
disease of the super elites of pharaohs
of royalty kings and queens and and
alike what's new about the late 90s and
the 21st century is that we all have
been struck or infected by affluenza
it's no longer just the the rich and the
elites affluenza is all pervasive so
much so that two-thirds of all of the
growth of the United States economy
comes from consumption alone and so you
can see why the head of the Federal
Reserve Board is so concerned about
about consumption next I'd like to
examine some of the forces at work
promoting affluence some of the driving
forces so to speak having outlined some
of the root causes and basically there
are six not surprisingly at the top of
the list is the media internet schools
colleges religious institutions and
finally the US government in terms of
the media the basically corporate since
corporate America owns controls and
operates most of the print media and the
electronic media in this this country
it's not surprising them that the media
basically tells us what to buy how much
to pay for when to to replace it it
essentially tells us so what's what's
cool a more recent done form of a
carrier a promotion of of affluenza is
the is the internet before the e bubble
burst millions of people in our country
had turned to cyberspace but virtually
everything from information employment
business shopping
entertainment and low-cost
telecommunications to more
transcendental benefits such as
spirituality worship even meaning and
community college graduates saw the
internet is the ticket to fame fortune
financial security and
self-actualization grassroots democracy
in some cases the net was their virtual
God a God perceived to be much more
responsive than the biblical one it
provided an altar where the human mind
could be downloaded and sacrifice for
Speed greed power and instant
gratification the intense frenzy with
which we embrace the ubiquitous Internet
was reminiscent of the 19th century gold
rush and the Texas and California oil
booms were mesmerized by the techno
height being dished out by Silicon
Valley Wall Street and the ivory tower
viewed by many as a limitless electronic
marketplace President Bill Clinton
called the net our new town square some
sight is a common global postal system
shopping mall library and university an
essential tool of life it was also a
place where you could unsuspectingly be
placed under homepage arrest and
detained endlessly against your will
particularly if you are easily seduced
by advertising images rock music cool
sounds or video games not since the
advent of the automobile has any
technology proven to be more seductive
more revered and more mystified than the
Internet not withstanding its usefulness
as a communication tool it's possible
that the net may be one of the most anti
intellectual anti educational anti
creative anti social tools ever
conceived its potential to destroy
community undermine democracy create a
spiritual vacuum and induce emotional
stability is unprecedented so media and
Internet are two of the driving forces
so
influencing or promoting affluenza the
third and fourth are schools and
colleges and universities and I'll kind
of lump folks together I mean one would
hope that schools and colleges and
university might might challenge the
popular culture the conventional culture
but it seems like more the time that our
schools and colleges are defining what
school telling us what to wear which
movies to see which of the right CDs to
acquire essentially how to live our
lives somewhat more surprising our
institution in terms of its impact would
be our religious institutions at least
in the past you could count on some
churches synagogues and mosques to uh to
raise questions about the popular cult
culture to to even confront or engage
people and how they they apply but when
I think about religious institutions I
think of the case a few years ago in a
local Congregational Church nearby in
which happened to be Christmas Sunday
and the the kids in the church anxious
to hear a Christmas story moved to the
front of the the church and but was
surprised when the minister rather than
giving them the annual Christmas story
essentially went around the room and
asked each kid to say what he or she had
been given by Santa Claus on the night
before three months later it was Easter
Sunday and the same Minister of this
time who was expected to tell an Easter
story turned to the to the same kids and
said now tell me what the Easter Bunny
brought you the night before and I mean
this is this is a bit ironic because in
this particular religion the notion that
it's more blessed to give than receive
is kind of fundamental to their belief
structure and and yet the message from
the minister was what's really important
on Christmas and Easter is how much
stuff did you get either from Santa or
the Easter rabbit the the last of the
institutions promoting are hyping our
affluence or but by no means least would
be the United States government itself I
think it's actually not an overstatement
to say that in these days affluenza has
become official US government policy in
our nation the Federal Reserve the
Congress and the president are all
unconditionally committed to the
promotion and the hyping of affluenza
they are I felt previously about the
Federal Reserve Board last year under
Alan Greenspan's direction the board cut
interest rates a record 11 times all
aimed primarily at preventing the
possibility of consumer fatigue syndrome
and heaven forbid impeding the flow of
effluent
so to speak the Congress Hartley was out
of whimper last summer easily passed
President Bush's one point three five
trillion dollar tax tax cut all aimed at
stimulating the economy and increasing
the spread of affluenza and reducing the
risk of consumer fatigue syndrome and
then more recently the president george
w bush himself back in World War two
President Franklin Delano Roosevelt
admonished uh young men at the time to
join the military don't wait to be
drafted go to the Pacific and go to
Europe risk your lives for the sake of
your nation president george w bush
admonished us in terms of fighting
terrorism to basically buy or fly go to
the mall and buy something buy anything
or hop on a jet and fly to Orlando where
is it's brother happens to be governor
and and go to Disneyworld buy or fly is
official government policy let's turn
now to two effects of of affluenza the
effect on the environment and the effect
on global terrorism I think in order to
address both of these issues both the
environmental consequences and global
terrorism we need to have a brief look
at American foreign policy it seems to
me that these days American foreign
policy rests on two fundamental premises
one is to the rest of the world be like
us and the second one is might makes
right consider the environmental
question the United States so the
population of about two hundred and
eighty million people represents five
percent of the global population yet we
produce one-third of all the stuff
that's produced in this world of the
global output is produced in the USA
therefore it's not surprising that we on
a daily basis use about 25 percent of
all the crude oil supply for the day and
in turn produce 25 percent of the carbon
dioxide which is thought to be the
leading cause of global warming in the
country if we then compare ourselves to
China the biggest country in the world
which has about 1.2 billion people 20%
of the world's population they only
produce 11 percent of the co2 from
emissions from oil related production ah
but but think of the possibilities
if the message from the United States
from corporate America to China is be
like us and suppose that every Chinese
household to take us literally and have
two automobiles and two or three
computers and all the other stuff that
we've got I mean there's no way that the
earth could could sustain I mean it
would take multiple earths just to
support China alone with all the
resources required to make that don't at
work not unrelated to the environmental
problem is that is the Terrorism problem
I mean the official foreign policy these
days seems to be to try and pin all the
blame on one person on sama bin Laden or
a group of Arab fanatics I would like to
suggest that I think that the underlying
causes of global terrorism are much more
complex than that simplistic analysis
and that we should begin right where we
just left off with the environment and
and on oil that the United States in
order to satisfy its huge appetite for
petroleum oh we have to import 60% of
all of our crude oil each day and a
significant amount of that comes from
the Middle East from places like Saudi
Arabia and other undemocratic Arab
fiefdom
even though for the last 20 years
official US foreign policy has said that
the kind of bedrock of our foreign
policy was human rights it was human
rights in all parts of the world except
the Middle East so the combination of
our dependence on oil and the fact that
we ignore the undemocratic nature of
most of the country Arab oil-producing
countries in the Middle East I think is
an important consideration another
consideration in the linkage between
affluenza and globalization would
between affluenza and and terrorism
would be globalization specifically I'm
thinking of
the mcdonaldization of the world and the
paving of the earth with Walmart's their
30,000 McDonald's today in 120 different
countries and nearly 4,500 Walmart's
well back to the two premises of foreign
policy which I suggested earlier it's
just be like us and that's of course
what what McDonald's and Walmart are
really all about having so many
McDonald's and Walmart's but just in
case you don't want to be like us
there is the second dimension of our
foreign policy which is basically
political economic technological and
military might make right and the
primary objective seems to be to make
the world safe for McDonald's Walmart
Boeing 747 sevens gas-guzzling SUVs the
internet bill gate and the gates and the
other members of the Forbes 400 and then
finally the last factor linking
affluenza to the global terrorism would
be the huge income gap between the rich
nations and the poor nations
particularly between ourselves and and
third world countries and a reminder
that there are 1.5 billion people
throughout this world out of 5 billion
plus who try to live on only one dollar
a day so before we are so presumptuous
as to try and blame terrorism on one
person or one small group of fanatics
maybe we should have a second look at
what Pogo said to us 30 years ago namely
we have met the enemy and he is us
next I would like to turn to the book
affluenza itself and the medical
metaphor that we use the book is much
lighter than what I've had to say about
the philosophy in the last 15 or 20
minutes it happens to be a laced with
klar tunes by David horsey a young
Seattle cartoonist as many of you know
this is a case where the the movie
preceded the the book rather than the
usual other way around affluence is
based on a 1997 documentary that
appeared on PBS and a follow-up
documentary called escape from affluenza
both of which were written and produced
by the lead author of the book John de
Graaff book is basically divided into
three parts not surprisingly given the
medical analogy symptoms causes and
treatments some of the chapter headings
for the symptoms include shopping fever
rash of bankruptcies swollen
expectations chronic congestion dilated
pupils community chills and an ache for
meaning the causes in it since I have
already covered in my introductory
remarks on the philosophical
underpinnings essentially the the bottom
line of what I had to say
philosophically is that effluence is
firmly grounded in the human condition
and by the human condition I mean what
we all share in common is is a sense of
separation a lack of connectedness of
our lives a lack of community the fact
that our lives often lack purpose or
lack meaning and thirdly a sense of
powerlessness and that is how how much
influence or how much power can one feel
when one stands in the presence of a
Walmart
Donald's or mobile Exxon or any of these
humongous transnational mega
corporations or better still when we
stand at the feet of the United States
government a government where which more
often than not elections are bought in
sold to the highest bidder
and then finally the fourth element of
the human condition that I'm speaking of
would be fear of our own mortality fear
of our own death so separation
meaninglessness powerlessness and fear
of mortality are really the underlying
root causes of effluent zone and so what
I'm suggesting is that that affluenza is
first and foremost a spiritual problem
which raises the question two or three
hundred years ago or maybe even in the
days of Henry David Thoreau sooner than
two or three hundred years ago
how did traditional societies deal with
the problems of the human condition of
separation meaninglessness powerlessness
and fear of mortality when they were not
in two to affluenza
I think they the answer is probably lies
in religions spirituality their
collective memory the traditional
culture and perhaps their sense of
community the last section of the of the
book deals with treatments and these
chapters have a light touch also to be
sure we're not suggesting that there are
any quick fixes to affluence but
affluenza is in many ways it's like drug
and alcohol addiction but ultimately
it's a question of will if you decide
that you want to to break out of that
fluence and rid yourself of this this
disease some of the chapters include bed
rest you know kool-aid aspirin and
chicken soup there's a fresh-air chapter
another one called vaccinations and
vitamins their political prescriptions
but I would be the first add that I
don't
that the u.s. government has stands a
prayer of being able to solve the
problem of affluence I mean how are you
going to pass legislation against
affluenza if everybody who's going to
vote in the legislation is into
affluence so it's a kind of
self-defeating cycle Rob's the most
important chapter is called annual
checkups this chapter even begins with a
diagnostic test which you can give
yourself and in determine whether or not
you're infected with affluenza and then
there are various so rules of thumb and
procedures you might apply to yourself
to see essentially whether what you're
buying all the stuff you're acquiring
really contributes much very much to
your sense of being or meaning who who
you think that you are I mean another
approach to the treatment of effluence
would be the simply the four R's reduce
reuse repair and recycle essentially
what we're suggesting is slow down
consider the possibility of working less
consuming less try to achieve a quieter
simpler more fulfilling life and above
all remember that the best things in
life are not things lastly I would like
to turn to Vermont itself is a kind of
an example case study that we might
consider is those those of you here at
the gala school know and others know too
Vermont is different from most states
it's very different the classic red
Barn's the covered bridges and the sugar
maples small forums black-and-white
Holsteins tiny villages little rubbers
ridges hollows dirt roads and the fact
that there are no commercial billboards
in the entire state of Vermont because
they like it that way Vermonters have
the highest percentage of unpaved roads
in the country and roadside billboards
have been banned since 1968
Vermont is smaller more rural more
democratic less violent much more
obstinate less commercial more
environmentally friendly more
egalitarian and more independent than
most states even though Vermont is too
small to save our nation from the
debilitating effects of separation
alienation powerlessness and spiritual
emptiness it does provide a
communitarian alternative to the
dehumanized mass production mass
consumption narcissistic lifestyle which
pervades much of the rest of the country
when Walmart the 200 billion dollar
Arkansas base retail Goliath now
literally the largest company in the
world
finally bullied its way into picturesque
Bennington Vermont it was a major defeat
for thousands of Vermonters who had
fought its entry into the Green Mountain
State tooth and nail Vermont was the
last state to succumb to the
heavy-handed retailer thought by some to
be the Great Satan the enemy of small
towns and small merchants everywhere
tiny Vermont was no match for the 4500
store Walmart Empire and its seductive
low prices it's a hundred and thirty
thousand square feet stores and 1.2
million employees the automobile
interstate highways shopping malls fast
food restaurants suburban sprawl have
all taken their toll on small Vermont
talents and villages once charming
villages in such places as Essex
Junction Williston Richmond and
Shelburne are now little more than
Burlington bedroom communities fill with
apartments and condominiums strip malls
in Burlington Bennington and Rutland are
as unsightly as those anywhere the state
has been blanketed by McDonald's Wendy's
Burger Kings Pizza Huts and KFC's
remindes experienced increased
difficulty in protecting itself from the
debilitating effects of big business big
agriculture big markets and big
government who basically want all of us
to be the same
just like they are over 200 years ago
Ethan Allen and his Green Mountain Boys
help save remind from New York
landowners today the threat to Vermont
comes not from Yorkers but from
globalization since the days of Ethan
Allen Vermont has always been different
but not for much longer
the globalization of Vermont is progress
much faster and much farther than anyone
thought possible
the tiny one side illa Green Mountain
State they soon become just another
colony of a handful of transnational
mega companies only this time around
there's no Ethan Allen to save Vermont
from America are the rest of the world
ok mm-hmm
now welcome questions or comments
there's a roving microphone that will be
brought to you any other question
I'm just curious about your views of you
mentioned earlier the older days 200 300
years ago back in colonial times
literacy rates promote spur much higher
than they are now and I'm wondering what
kind of effect you see between that and
this whole consumer ignoring Family
Values kind of effects today kind of a
bad question the way I phrased it but
let me restate that mimei what
correlation if any can you see between
the lack of a strong community and the
emplacement of a mechanical system toys
etc big tractors in regards to people
clothing a day's weather sticks and
their little hoops they were knocking
around the streets with what kind of
effect do you see that that's had on our
current society I think there's some
extent all of our stuff it's so
seductive it's so enticing that we're
drawn to the the quick instantaneous
response of whether it be a computer or
some other high-tech device rather than
say the patience of sitting around by
the fireplace with the family
entertaining themselves and that
requires a lot more effort to tell
stories to sing songs recite poetry than
the instantaneous response of many of
the toys that we are so attracted to
think that would be would be part of it
other questions one in the back Murray
um Thomas I'm wondering how you day by
day live by what you preach about
solutions to affluenza that's a tough
question um well like everyone else say
I suspect in this room I too and
infected with effluent so I guess the
best answer I can give is I uh I think
about it i try to consciously weigh my
decisions as to whether this particular
article clothing gadget whatever it may
be you know whether it's really really
really necessary but my message is aimed
squarely at myself as well as everyone
else
all right I have a comment that I'd like
to make and then a question my comment
is that I have seen creativity basically
annihilate f1 'aa over and over again if
someone creates their own clothing and
creates their own music creates their
own artwork it's so much more fulfilling
than going to the store and buying
something that someone else has made and
even bought and even receiving something
from a friend that they've made is more
fulfilling than going to a store and
that my question is how do you see
lowering the ever-rising standard of
living in the United States right now
alright yeah the how much we think we
need to have and how do you see lowering
we could lower that yeah I Sam Russell
you're speaking of really the whole
question of growth versus no growth
suggesting if if there was less growth
it would be perhaps a lower standard of
living I mean part of the reason we're
so obsessed with growth in this country
is so long as you can hold out to a poor
person the possibility that you two can
get a little bit more even though you've
got an infinitesimally small piece of
the pie you're going to be able to get a
little bit more of the bigger pie than
you had before that will keep you quiet
and kind of in your place and so the
politicians have a very strong veterus
vested interest in perpetuating the
growth machine this this is why every
administration that we've had certainly
in the the 20th century and 21st century
and the White House is always committed
to to growth because if it's not a
growth economy then the native so to
speak get restless and start worrying
about my share of the pie whether it's
whether
it should be bigger than yours etc and
so so the growth distracts people away
from the questions of income
distribution it's true that in the short
one if you were to have a no growth
economy or start to slow the growth that
some people you know would not be as
well-off as they have been in the past
but over the long haul what's required
is showing is that there are
alternatives to more and more stuff and
you mentioned some of them yourself in
the beginning of your piece the the
pleasure of making one's own clothes
ones creating one's own music that
that's over the long haul more
meaningful and more important source of
happiness than just buying something off
of the the shelf even though it may give
you instant gratification
it's three in the front
okay
um first of all I'd like to agree with
Russell's previous comment about
creating your own things I completely
agree with that and then also I was
thinking do you think that fallen living
under voluntary simplicity like do you
think having less would make someone
happier necessarily not not necessarily
I think that it it takes a kind of
change in state of mind as well I mean
there's certainly a lot of people who's
who live simple lives you did use the
caveat voluntarily that a lot of people
who have simple lives in our country are
are in that position not out of choice
and so the life is very tough for them
over time I think it's a it's a question
of really ultimately a state of mind
thanks for your comments on foreign
policy and I appreciate your your
warnings about some of the things that
are not admirable about our foreign
policy one of my concerns though is that
we know some level of affluence for
especially the poorest countries could
make a tremendous difference in a
positive difference in terms of
healthcare for people around the world
basic health care clean water and I
wonder if you can describe for us as an
economist what kind of a foreign policy
should we have in this country what
kinds of goals should we be working to
promote for countries around the world
with our actions if if not our current
policy you understand my question
yes sure oh well I think maybe bastardos
perhaps a bit more humility a
realization or an acknowledgement that
we can't solve all of the world's
problems even though we are the world's
only global superpower but but perhaps
being a bit more patient asking the
right questions about what do these
countries want what are their needs are
not simply trying to impose the World
Bank the WTO or the IMF formula for
economic development upon them
essentially for the last 30 years the
economic model that our government has
been unconditionally committed to comes
from the economics Department of the
University of Chicago it's a very
specific narrowly defined free market
model and in most economies like myself
like free markets but but free markets
are not a panacea on that there that can
be risk in problems with them and that
we need to ask I think more questions of
the clients not simply hastily saying be
like us and then as I suggest that if
you don't like it
be prepared to pay
my question is whether you think that it
would be at all possible or even
effective to have an enforced limit on
spending and buying rather than
depending on people's individual
decisions to try to treat the problem
that of affluenza oh my answer would be
no a few economists would favor any kind
of forced imposition of this I mean the
starters I think you could never get it
passed and in the Congress we're so
hooked on Ethel and so it's
inconceivable that that could could pass
but even if it were to pass people would
find some way around that as I suggested
earlier in my remarks I really don't
think the government is going to fix the
problem of effluent it's got to come
from within now one one government
policy that I believe has some merit is
perhaps rather than a straight sales tax
that every state has in the United
States there could be a kind of up of
affluenza tax or luxury tax with a
sliding scale upward that is a higher
percentage would be levied you know if
you were buying a Mercedes then perhaps
if you were buying a Volkswagen and that
you would have to pay there will be a
form of moving in the direction that
you're talking about
which i think is about as far as one
could expect to be able to go let's see
okay um I in our DaVinci's nine class we
talked a lot about religion and I was
wondering uh there's a UH an idea that
you're born with original sin do you
think that this has the f lenses kind of
that same sort of concept that you're
born with it or that you kind of inherit
it through the media interesting
question Oh to some extent on when I
said that the death fluence of stems
from separation meaninglessness
powerlessness and fear of death that
could be like a kind of analogy to a
original sin essentially arguing it's
the human condition and we all suffer
from those those conditions in it we
arrive with that problem from day one
and we depart with it also so I'm
wondering how your experiences in the
world corporate society heaven have
influenced your current views on it um
they've had a lot of a lot of influence
on me because so about twenty years of
my life I was in the computer software
business and my feel was computer
simulation modeling and worked a lot
with larger corporations and and so I
had an opportunity to see from the
inside some of the problems and and also
how they they operate to some extent I
guess my present views could could be
expressed as a kind of reaction against
the culture that I lived in for about 20
20 years that second thoughts so to
speak Martha
what to what effect do you think
campaign finance reform will have on how
officials are elected in the United
States in term of in terms of
eliminating corporations soft money etc
well ideologically I'm strongly in favor
of campaign reforms and would applaud it
hope that it would happen
I guess realistically I'm very
pessimistic about it because I think the
the transnational mega corporations in
the United States have so much power
that they will never allow it to happen
I mean there may be some small movement
around the fringes but I don't think it
has a chance of passing reform that has
any real bite in the back um yeah you
said like you said that Vermont does
note doesn't is the only state that
doesn't allow billboards and do you
think how long do you think it's going
to be until the government in Vermont
succumbs to the media and allows divorce
to be put up oh no what I'm fairly
optimistic I think the the anti
billboards cinemates in Vermont are
probably here to stay hopefully
I'm wondering if you think companies
such as Microsoft and the government who
just gets in stalemates do you think
companies such as Microsoft and the
other big companies are progressing
affluenza and just continuing it a lot
um and what did you say about the
government also you're they get and the
government can't really do much about it
yeah it's actually I considered um Bill
Gates and Bill Clinton to be two of the
all-time biggest promoters of effluence
or ever to walk on the face of this
earth Bill Gates and Bill Clinton two of
a kind
any other questions one more question
what Dolan well you suggested that the
problem is not these conditions of
meaninglessness and powerlessness but
how we go about solving them can you
make some suggestions to our students
about how they might search for meaning
in alternative ways Oh
nice easy question ah I think one way to
start is by reviewing the bidding you
know asking yourself over the last
fourteen eighteen years of your life to
prepare a list of the really meaningful
and meaningless events in your life
follow that maybe by a stab at a kind of
personal philosophy Who am I
what am I about my values my sense of
ethical being and and finally a a kind
of personal strategic plan what do I
want to be when I grow up that's a kind
of simplistic process but that's all the
time that we've got done one less
do you think there's a way to stop as
flu Enza like completely so that there's
none anywhere oh absolutely not and in
fact we're not I guess in our book our
objective was not to stop effluence or
or art - certainly not - stop
consumption but but really to provide a
few thoughts about how we might put the
brakes on to it to at least slow it down
bring it more into control consistent
with our own values our own philosophy
and who we are as a as an individual
thank you very much for being with us
today and thanks so to the people from
c-span as well good day